في قلق وجدل وضجه في العالم عاملها لقاء
جمع بين اثنين من الشخصيات الاكثر جدلا
مبسط في امريكا بل في العالم الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وكان يوستا او يي لكن
سبب الجدل والضجه مبسها الدوله الاثنين
اللي تقوم من قبل ومعروف انه علاقتهم اوكي
يعني لكن الجدل سببه شخص ثالث حضر معاهم
اسمه نك فينتس هذا معروف عنه انك انه من
دعاه تفوق العرق الابيض العشق كان في مره
لا يقوم مقر اقامه ترامب في فلوريدا واللي
حابب يعرف ايش سبب الاشياء خلينا نسمع
اشكال عنه همم
ترامبوز موت
يبغى يترشح للانتخابات
موضوع وطبعا وسط كل هذه الاذنات
والاستنكار طلع ترامب واصدر بيان على منصه
دروس سوشل قال فيه انه العشاء كان على
اساس هو وكان لوحدهم وهو تفاجئ بثلاثه من
اصحاب كان يا معاون العشاء كان هادئ ومن
بعده راحوا على المطار وبخصوص ما تم نقاش
وفي العشاء قالت رب انه الكلام كان مو
عظمه نصائح بزنس اللي كانوا وكلام السياسه
كان قليل جدا ونصحوا بعدم الترشح اصلا
والاهم من كل هذا قال انه اصلا ما يعرف
مين هو
هذا اللي بيقول اعرفه والثاني بيقول معجب
فين عموما حتى مسلسله بوستات ردود وبس
اختصر فيه الموقف وقال انا كنت باحاول
اساعد شخص مضطرب يعني كده قالب قال انه في
شخص مضطرب خسران كل شيء الان كنت احاول
اساعده جالي مع ثلاثه ما اعرفهم وهذه
الجزائر في الاخير الاعلام المزيف الجنه
[موسيقى]